hey guys today we're doing something
super super incredible and you know I'm
into it today we are going to be in zero
gravity I've always wanted to be an
astronaut and I think probably the
closest I'm going to get I don't have
the education and I don't have the
eyesight for it so today is the day feet
down coming out me gravity is about the
ticket back when you hear that make sure
that you're not doing any somersaults
returns make sure that your feet are
straight down and get ready to come down
to the ground so in this plane making
parallel explainers basically the plane
slides up super super quick and then as
dropping you are weightless for about
thirty seconds we're flying for a
modified Boeing 727 aircraft at the same
altitude as tomorrow's life the first
two were not entirely weightless is to
kind of get our body acclimated so let
me tell you one that is terrifying hates
flying so let's do nothing you know what
I was a little nervous going into this
but everybody I've talked to that is
going on the flight with us I've done
Mike over 300 flights so I feel pretty
good about it let me end of dying in
auditioning
life
[Music]
Oh may I have mention super daughter's
children visually on the plane I'll
basically get to the hollowed out 727
and there is B pier in the back and here
is simply things off then we go into the
cabin lay down let me tell you what I
made a mistake of doing Isis q slow the
motion sickness tablets and it makes
tired
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
thank you guys so much for watching this
video I just finished editing it so I am
now just bringing this entire video to a
close and a huge thank you to Sony and
the movie passengers they were the ones
that sent us all up there and gave us
incredible opportunities so thank you
guys so much
it seemed like these but you will just
absolutely never ever ever forget so if
you ever get an opportunity to do
anything like this even if you're
terrified it doesn't matter what it is
do it because there is a really good
chance that it could be one of the most
incredible experiences of your life with
that being said I will see you guys soon
in my next video thanks again for
watching and I will see you later I just
want to go rewatch this video which I
think I might just do a PS not through
up man I wish I want to playback I can I
know it I know it
ah now after this I'm going to say that
I just kind of what I've been working
with some of the armor that I've got and
my map so if you don't want any spoilers
don't watch the end of this video I
won't really give you any real spoilers
who don't worry and me I don't care I
want to know everything so if there's
anything that you want to tell me about
the to tell me right below because
whatever you tell me I'm going to go try
to find the media